Have you ever wondered why humans are the
only species capable of talking?
If chimps are so smart, why can’t they speak!?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you’re
like me, every so often weird thoughts will
pop into your head, and you won’t be able
to stop thinking about them until you figure
out the answer.
This morning, it was - why can’t chimps
speak?
Which is great - because it turns out there
was an article published just today, about
that very subject.
Scientists have discovered the reason behind
humans’ unique ability to produce and understand
speech, and it turns out - it may have arisen
from a gene mutation over half a million years
ago.
That gene is called FoxP2, and it exists in
both humans and chimps.
Its connection to language, was first discovered
in a group of family members who had severe
difficulties with speaking and understanding
speech - and that family was found to be carrying
a mutated version of the gene.
Back in 2009, there was a study published
in Nature about FoxP2, showing that the human
and chimp versions of the gene, not only look
different - but function differently too.
Somewhere around the time humans began developing
the capacity for speech, our FoxP2 gene became
mutated.
And that mutation, resulted in different gene
targets being switched on or off in human
and chimp brains.
In that study, scientists genetically engineered
mice to express the human form of FoxP2.
Mice who were given that mutation, learned
to run a maze much more quickly than normal
mice, meaning their learning capacity was
effectively enhanced.
Specifically, they developed the ability to
turn mindful actions into behavioral routines
- which is a necessary learning process for
developing language.
It hinges on 2 key types of memories: declarative
memory, which is the memory of events and
places, and procedural memory - which is needed
for routine tasks.
In humans, those two types of memories work
in conjunction with each other.
So when somebody shows us a hand, for example,
and says the word “hand” - we’re transforming
the experience of hearing that word, into
an automatic association.
Meaning our brains now associate the word
hand, with objects that look and function
like hands.
And once we learn that association, it’s
with us forever.
That’s why, when we’re performing routine
actions, like driving to work, we don’t
need to consciously think about it as we’re
doing it.
But that’s not really the case for other
species.
And our unique ability to do that, is an essential
part of how we’ve come to develop and understand
speech.
It’s crazy to think that a single gene mutation
could be responsible for our entire development
of language, but what’s crazier - is that
it doesn’t completely rule out the possibility
that other animals could someday develop speech.
Of course even if they did develop that mutation
naturally, it would still take thousands if
not millions of years to set in - but it does
make you wonder what would happen, if something
like that occurred.
Imagine someday being able to communicate
with chimps.
It’s like a weird, alternate reality version
of Planet of the Apes.
Kinda scary to think about.
But on the bright side, if it does happen
- we’ll all be dead by then!
And on that topic, I wanna remind you guys
that I host another show here on Discovery
called
Anyhoo, where we recently did an episode about
4 of the most gruesome unsolved murder cases.
So if you feel like getting grossed out, you
can watch that episode over at youtube.com/revision3.
And in the meantime, if you guys have any
questions, comments, fears about our impending
chimp overlords - just leave em in the comments
below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!